starwars alas Jedi is one of the biggest
cinematic spectacles of the air in
addition to returning characters like
Luke ray Finn and kylo Ren the eighth
film in the skywalker saga will add
several new faces like kelly marie tran
who's been referred to as the biggest
new part of the last Jedi in the film
she portrays Rose a member of the
resistance who worked side by side with
fan Kelly Marie Tran might not be a
household name yet but it won't be long
before her face is gracing thousands of
action figures and posters nonetheless
she might look awfully familiar to Star
Wars fans and with good reason here are
just a few of the places you may have
seen her before
webshots kelly marie tran grew up in san
diego california and caught the acting
bug early on in high school she took to
the stage appearing in plays musicals
and later alongside improv comedy
troupes throughout her education at UCLA
she eventually transitioned to doing
digital shorts and earned a first
starring role as a cast member of the
YouTube comedy series ladies like us a
meta commentary of sorts the web soccer
followed the adventures of three
would-be up-and-comers from an
all-female comedy troupe the series
explored the challenges of seeking out
fame and fortune in the wannabe
saturated world of Los Angeles and each
webisode also explored or parodied
standard character tropes like personal
insecurities bad boyfriends and
expectations foisted on women by
Hollywood and the media Transco key
character charms the audience and the
show's hip-hop fueled vibe and crude
elements are reminiscent of the ladies
from broad city about a boy Tran next
made her mark on the acting world by
landing a small role on the short-lived
NBC series about a boy based on Nick
Hornby's novel the show starred David
Walton and Minnie Driver and although
the series only lasted two seasons it
garnered a cult following and above
average critical ratings the one camera
sitcom shadowed manchild
singer-songwriter well as his awkward
relationship with his neighbors upset
his otherwise Libertines lifestyle on
the show Tran popped in twice as
Marguerite's
a thoroughly inattentive babysitter it
was hardly the breakout role for the
young actress but it did allow her to
flex a few comedic muscles on a major
network based sitcom PSA days it's part
of her foray into comedy tried also
starred in several mad
webisodes for college humor creating
some memorably amusing sketches among
the wittiest Clips was a role as a
member of a political correctness
monitoring Asian Council in ru Asian
enough she also dropped by a startup app
developer in the poignant yet funny Y
net neutrality matters and what you can
do to help of course not all of her PSAs
were quite as hilarious as those she
also appeared in one of the anti-smoking
truth campaign ads and ironically enough
it's one that had a Star Wars twist to
it
pop quiz a strand built a voice and a
personal brand on network TV the
burgeoning actress landed roles on
several web series like hope and Randy
where she played the roommates of the
lead couple in 2016
she wound up with a major role in a
full-length TV pilot about a band of
rowdy Bar trivia junkies Pub Quiz
followed a gang of screw-ups and the
misadventures as they sought to dominate
the liquor soda bar quiz world these are
all small potato projects in comparison
to the last Jedi but hey everybody's got
to start somewhere
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you love team
[Music]